بوجودك مرحبا بكم
في هذا الحوار الخاص من هنا في امسيه
توزيع جوائز مراسلنا بلا حدود
مدير صحيفه نوفايا كازيتا الوسيله
الاعلاميه المستقله التي تم تعليق نشاطها
في روسيا شكرا على حضورك معنا معنا
15 سنه
القتل
خطوره اليوم في العالم ولهذا يمكن نقول
بان حلمي لم يتحقق
زميلي العذب
ما يحدث في مساحات
الالاف من المدنيين اناس مسالمين اذا لا
اود هنا ان ابالغ في وصف المخاطر المحدقه
الخيار
عده الايام
لمده ثمان سنوات ونصف بتهمه نشر اخبار
كاذبه حيث كان قد صرح وندد في قناته على
اليوتيوب بقتل المدنيين في بوتشا لا شك
وان هذا الحكم القاسي يؤثر فيه ايضا الى
انه لا يمكن الحديث حاليا عن اي شيء
تقريبا في روسيا
اسمها اسمها
وصف ما يحدث حرب
الفتاه في الثلج مضحكه
وانا نائم في مجلس بلدي اسمه غريب رفض
تنظيم مسابقه رسم للاطفال قائلا انه لا
يمكن تنظيم مثل هذه المسابقه والبلد تخوض
حربا وادين بالسجن ثمانيه سنوات ونصف
لانه رفض تنظيم هذه المسابقه
وفي نفس الوقت
الرسميه
تفضلي كذلك الى اشخاص اخرين
بطبيعه الحال في الارض هو انه كيف اقتنع
الروس وانطلت عليهم هذه
الدعايه ولكن علينا ان نقر هنا بان فئه
كبيره نسبيا من الروس يعتقدون بما يقوله
اوكرانيا
ما ينفعش
في مدينه
التي كانت تدعو الى القضاء على الشعب
التونسي
اذا كل شخص يمكن ان يتاثر بالدعايه ويمكن
ان يقتنع بها فيما يتعلق بروسيا
لقراءنا وقررنا نتائجنا
راينا من حيث حسب الاراء ان 86% من قراءنا
يناهلون وهم ضد تماما الحرب
مباشره يجيب بي دي سياده الروس كل الروس
اذن على الرغم من كل الدعايه عدد او فقط
او 50% من الروس ما زالوا يدعمون وضعه حد
من الحرب والشروع في مفاوضات
في وضع اكثر هشاشه
كما تحلو له وكما توقعها في اوكرانيا
وبانهمين الموت الى البلاد ومطالبه
الامهات بابنائهم فان هذا الدعم الذي يحفظ
وان نظام بوتين ليس بهذه المتانه التي
يدعيها هو واخرون انا
لا يمكنني ان اقول كلمه
المساله
عندما يقول الاخصائيون في السياسه في
اوروبا بان النظام
وعلى عائلاتهم
هذا اولا ثانيا
ومن قبل يا رب
الخارج
اوروبا
في اوروبا اذا يتم شرائهم بالجمله
اداره كوبرا الشركات الروسيه مستشار
المانيا كلهم
ضموا الى افرقه بوتين وحتى الخامس من
ديسمبر من هذه السنه كانت اوروبا
يوميا للغاز والبترول النفط الروسي الحرب
طبعا مكلفه لروسيا ولكن من خلال حساب بسيط
هناك اتزان نظام
بوتين كان يعول على هذا امر اخر
اي دعايه تحتاج الى احتكار
299 وسيله اعلام كانت مستقله ومنفصله عن
النظام اغلقت واكثر من 300 شخص وصل بانهم
عملاء للخارج او اعداء الشعب
كل وسائل الاعلام الدوله
[موسيقى]
الشباب من عمرهم اقل من 35 سنه الاغلبيه
الساحقه منهم لا يدعمون الحرب في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وان تكون لهم قيم عاديه وان يسافر يدرسوا
بينما منهم
[موسيقى]
هذه الحرب
بين الاجداد
السؤال الاخير السيد مراتو هل تعتقد
بانهما زال بامكان رئيس بوتين ان ينتصر في
هذه الحرب من خلال الضغط على الاوروبيين
بواسطه اسعار الغاز واللاجئين الاوكرانيين
ربما حيث يعتقدوا الكثيرون هنا بان
اوكرانيا قد صمدت بانها قد تنتصر في نهايه
المطار هل ما زال الانتصار ممكنا بالنسبه
لبوتين
تحت تصرف بوت مصادر مهمه وموارد مهمه اولا
موارد ومصادر الاتحاد السوفياتيه التي
وردتناها عن الاتحاد السوفيتي اي ان هناك
مخزونات من الاسلحه موروثه من حكمه
الاتحاد السوفيتي وحق من وحتى من حقبه
الامبراطوريه
الاوروبيون عاده العهد عهدتهم ثلاثه سنوات
سته سنوات وعهدتين خمس سنوات كحد الاقصى
بينما
بالمقارنه سياسي اوروبي
كم رئيس فرنسي اظن بانه حتى لا يمكن له ان
يتذكر اسماء
الدوله اخر مهم لديه كذلك موارد الطاقه
ودعم جزء من جزء جزء الشعب الروسي ايتابست
مودلي بروبا حتى انه كذلك حصل على
تكنولوجيات واموال من اوروبا مالا يمكن ان
تقوم به روسيا هو ما يلي يمكن لروسيا ان
تدمر اوكرانيا مثلا البناء التحتيه
المحطات المدن
المباني ولكن لا يمكن لروسيا ان تحتل
اوكرانيا لن تنجح حبتا
شكرا
[موسيقى]